uh why don't we try
um let's go to is it
yan from norway yan from norway
yes sir yes sir how are you
i'm good thank you are you good safe
yeah yeah are you in oslo or where are
you
well i'm about uh one and a half hours
drive
away from myself so okay yeah how much
uh how many hours of sunlight a day do
you get right now
um well during colby
if i like look out the window i get some
but
no no no i mean not not you personally i
mean where you are yeah
i know we have i was just joking we have
about like
uh six to seven hours i think okay all
right
yeah no i was just wondering like
um because looking looking at the
situation
from norway like how um how do you think
you can like
fix um like
uh reclaim your integrity do you think
it's enough
do you think it's enough like trying to
put trump in his place because
i i can see it like even if you don't
manage to impeach him or
like giving giving him some some larger
repercussions yeah just trying that will
send
a really good signal like
it's a good signal just trying to
impeach him right but
it is um if he's not convicted you're
saying listen i think the rehabilitation
of the united states
is partially going to happen from just
having joe biden in the return of actual
diplomatic uh taking diplomacy seriously
i really do think that many countries
are eager
to get back to a normal relationship
with the us so i think just having joe
biden back
and a proper diplomatic corps and
ambassadors i think that will be a big
piece of it but i don't think that will
be enough i think the us is going to
have to become a leader on coronavirus
and and
uh to to regain some of the respect that
we lost under donald trump
i think the united states is going to
have to figure out you know trump
bailed on the iran deal for no reason
iran didn't break any of the rules
during the deal
the u.s is going to have to figure out
how to regain credibility there so i
think that
it will partially happen under biden
just because biden will be normal
but i think that there is still work to
do i don't think it will ultimately be
about whether the senate convicts trump
on
impeachment no no no but just sending
the signal and trying
that's that's yeah thank you man my
pleasure
john from norway all right make sure
you're getting that uh vitamin d
there um thanks to everybody who called
i am
out of time for today but i will take
calls again in the future
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video